you
hi everyone is cherry I'm on leeches org
and I just got paired up playing a 15-2
game okay let's go with Knight to f6
standard chess woo Bishop g5 okay that's
different
Trump off ski huh alrighty well I could
go with the d5 or 94 played both I'm
fine with double deaf pawns
however let's play it where I don't even
allow that imbalance 94 it is in my D
from here is just to follow up next with
d5 let's see what white does I've seen
this move before I don't want to take
that bishop if h4 I don't want to help
out that rook all right let's follow up
with d5 establish a foothold in the
center all right and what about c5 right
now I want to get in a quick c5 Knight
c6 anything wrong without
let's go for it and see what kind of
trouble light tries to cause I'm not
concerned about Bishop takes Knight
sometimes maybe this would be something
within Bishop b5 but I can always block
alrighty
I could play Bishop f5 I think I'm
perfectly content with dropping my
knight back here I think this is a a
fine approach to this opening next up
Knight here okay I don't think that this
pawn
could have been captured and maintained
or at the very least I would have some
pressure if they tried to go pawn
grabbing first things first this Knight
definitely belongs here and this is
without question not best I could get an
e5 in one shot have a nice Center and
then conveniently recapture alright well
can I not just play Bishop to g4 and
then e six very solid approach something
a bit more aggressive would be Queen b6
striking at B - but I don't know if I'm
so much a fan of going pawn hunting I'd
I feel like in a way if I'm playing
Queen b6 I'd just kind of bluffing about
taking b2 I don't wanna I don't want to
be a bluffer I want to really be
threatening to take that pawn if I play
Queen to b6 and I don't know if I'm up
to the task I think I could play this
position a bit more calm and have a fine
position so the the move that I'm really
looking into and I don't know that I
really have any other candidate move
besides it is Bishop to g4
where would the Queen go hmm I don't
think she's really bothering me like I
don't think she would bother me if she
came out here here white would in fact
have to be concerned some they're
playing Queen the beats free I think I
could just play Bishop g4 I don't see
any issue with it well it's well let's
go for that Bishop g4 it is this is our
first time playing myself in fan B 18 a
good player let's see what fan B comes
up with f3 would be pretty aggressive
okay now just something normal
okay alright well I know where my e pawn
belongs I'm not looking to fee and
kettle or anything
I want my Bishop here to recapture this
is the structure I'm working with a 6 d
5 C 5 versus this so these two offset
these to offset and really the main
difference within the structure is
related to the C pawns c3 vs c5 and of
the two I have the more aggressive C
pawn how are we doing timewise not over
here time here time I got three minor
pieces out they have four I still need
one two three moves before I have a
connection between my rooks only two for
white okay
now that is aggressive my lights and a
pin so they're really trying to take
advantage of my night here
huh is that what's happening preparing
Knight to e5 are we hmm okay I have to
be careful here the first sure also I
mean this has a reminds me some of uh
Cambridge Springs
you know this Queen now has some lateral
influence on the black end you'd have
influence on v Frank so yeah this is the
idea Knight to e5 how do we address this
one of my first thoughts was Knight d7
and with the Bishop on f4 there is not
this you know there's still a piece
interfering with the Queen grabbing my
Bishop however if I go Knight d7 and
takes I know I could recapture and
Beyond the Queen okay so I really would
not be fearing 97 and then pawn takes
yeah I shouldn't be concerned about that
this is to combat 95 that way I could
just take him out
yeah I wonder if I could also just take
the night I don't want to be too quick
to give up my light square bishop if I
have the time I would really like to do
this do I have the time hmm what else
would I have besides Knight to d7 here
this concerns me because of this move
and chop chop Bishop here and I could
easily lose the exchange you could have
both of these bishops control all of
these squares of my rook will be a goner
before you know it so I think the move
here is Knight to d7
what about c4 I'll release the tension
on d4 but now I feel like that's too
early and then II four will be strong
elite they'll happily just back up okay
well let's let's run with this I've
invested enough time too much time maybe
let's go at night d7 and see what white
comes up with it's Bishop to b5 that
Bishop moves again I have Queen b6 I
don't think that that's so much of an
inconvenience Queen b6 develops defense
e6 there's a big fight going on right
now over the e5 square some tension on
e5 I want to
careful of this move in playing Queen b6
that's a good way to lose because here
here pawn takes pawn Knight takes can
now be met with Queen here if they take
at this moment there isn't that move so
this may be a thought maybe yeah maybe
White is crunching the numbers on that
move however I think I'm fine with just
playing Bishop e7 Bishop takes Queen
takes pawn takes I first play Bishop
takes Knight and only then recapture on
c5 and I think all as well maybe even I
come out ahead slightly I think the
timing in on board will be even ish and
I will have a better structure not much
but something if they're going with this
right they're giving up their strong
center point a point that they have
reinforced many times now well a couple
times with the pawn so you really white
should have something I should really be
getting something if they're making this
capture to give up that strong point so
these are maybe some moves trying to
possibly take advantage of the fact that
my knight is no longer around
controlling d5 nor is my queen okay well
I had in mind Queen here
that's a game loser Bishop takes Knight
I lose a piece
Queen b6 was my thought
any tactical issue
it is a loose piece here Queen b6 I
don't think that there's any issue yeah
let's let's just go with going to be six
have to be to be able look out
still a couple pieces in between the
Queen and the bishop there there's no
good Bishop move to allow for this
sequence yeah
this isn't they give up the bishop for
the knight in order to give me doubled
pawns that's just imaginary those really
are not doubled pawns they will be
undone by force chop-chop
although I don't know if I'm immediately
recapturing on my beep on but in the end
I have these to the C pawn will be
exchanged for this guy okay just doing a
normal move I like to see that and maybe
I should just get on with Bishop to e7
and then Castle kingside
let's do it I want to bring it to a
point where I am one move away from
castling I don't want to be two moves
behind that maybe two too many
I'm still fine with this capture of the
recapturing with my night as it stands
right now these my second ranked night
and white second ranked night are boxed
out by the D pawns so neither of us
likes our nights a great deal
not the greatest minor pieces around I
like that my opponents thinking usually
uh there's like about a 3-minute
difference Tanner saw moves in my
opponents a thinker good to see expected
what should white do what would I do if
I was playing one here can always grab a
a tempo against the bishop and say AHA I
have a flight square now and I did so
with gain of time but maybe I'm not so
upset with getting my Bishop to a bit
more safe square alright so 95 okay well
probably have to take this was the idea
oh oh you clever got you I see it now
huh
okay this is getting uh this is getting
sharp because when I take care bishop
takes their on this and then threatening
that capture being on my Bishop and as
it stands right now my bishops under
fire so I don't have very many options
here I probably have to take the knight
and then go from there huh
but fortunately fortunately on this
capture that's interesting how this is
working out Knight takes bishop takes I
believe I could just castle to defend
here on then pawn takes pawn I could
take with no that's not completely
accurate Bishop could take here first I
was thinking I could I have some threat
to take their Bishop hmm
I wonder if Bishop e7 was to yeah I
wonder if I should have captured the
knight or backed up this is now starting
to be an issue down
minutes yeah this is this is a problem I
think also I mean this is a threat I
probably just have to take that night ah
yeah so now this is a threat oh wait a
second I just miscalculate Oh you know
after after this capture can I actually
just castle
no I can't that's right they're going to
going to take here hmm okay I may have
to play something weird like a six right
around here right now this is a threat
this is a threat c4 maybe c4 is a move
or even capture hmm see if I do this and
they go pawn grabbing I think in the end
I have this move and I get the exchange
so is this the saving idea c4 here just
to stop this capture and getting my
bishop it maybe can also back up
similar idea no not quite my bishop
needs to be here for this little tactic
here and then this there right under
five I think I'm leaning towards c4 here
the bishop can return here meet bishop
h3o bishop g3 hmm
okay maybe I'm leaning towards a ha6
here hmm and try to play down upon but I
have the bishop hair and an ending um I
feel like I'm going to be down upon hmm
yeah let's try this yeah I I they took
advantage of a this the z7 move I think
Bishop e7 this I take with the Queen and
I'm on the Queen so there's no time for
this so they should just take my knight
here I think you know this here here I'm
on the amount of the bishop so ooh that
moved first okay well this I drop my
rook so I think I just have to do this
now they'll take here and now that my
bishop is protected maybe I could keep
the Queen's on although I don't have a
great shelter for my King do I hmm
think I want the Queen's off I'm a bit
surprised that this move hasn't already
been played what else would there be oh
okay maybe maybe they are considering
this capture now but that they'd be
working into a pin if they try to hunt
down my bishop I'm fine with the
LightSquared Bishop exchange if the
Queen ends up here I'll I'll be able to
take advantage of that pin somehow this
this huh
am I missing something there's some
other move here besides Bishop takes
Knight we're going to see you know
they'll be able to hang on to the pawn I
don't have this idea here I think I'll
be taking with the clean yes yeah
Queens off and Bishop e5 and then on
Bishop h3 there's this this Bishop b5
here another surprising moment I don't
think that there's anything but Queen
takes Queen there so now Bishop here
Bishop h3 Bishop g3 alright Bishop hair
endgame but I'm down upon also the
bishop on e3 or e4 does not allow me to
get to the B file so easily I could try
to glue my bishop in here and maybe that
Bishop is uh can be annoying I'm looking
now at situations where I can have it an
opposite color Bishop ending possibly so
maybe starting with this here and then
this move is something hmm should I give
this bishop a boot first huh less than
three
hmm yeah
maybe even this is a move within a for
once keep my bishop right where it's at
can't really make up my mind I mean he
could still eventually end up here I
have to be careful of this advance but I
have good support here I'm leaning it
I'm looking at having my King on d7 I
may need to try to fight also on the
clock some if I could try to put some
pressure on my opponent on the clock hmm
I wonder what the evaluation would be
saying right here I don't think it's a
full point advantage for white there's
value in these guys for sure and also
you know there's this capture here could
have a strong pawn Center I mean the
extra pawn that white has for the moment
is not a contributor to the center it's
a Jeep on that white is up so everything
else let's say right around here is kind
of offset the the pawns fight each other
well
okay well I guess we're going to go here
I don't want to do this because of just
this move and also I may want to grab a
tempo against their Bishop with up six
at some point on this move I'm prepared
to back up I don't want to give up my
strong pawn as I was mentioning earlier
and the D pawns are were killing both of
our Knights to back up I'm looking at
this they've opened up this diagonal
this Bishop goes away from b8 get some
pressure against this pawn on Knight to
b3 I'm prepared well they have to do
something with this mm okay they're
ready to come out me here check out with
f6 and then King here hmm
let's get let's get Mike hangout for the
same files that rook and how how safe
can you feel and eh alright yeah I
really want to be able to go here but I
don't see how I chase this Bishop off
the diagonal hmm interesting
rook up and over
let's try for that first kind of a
clamping down some may look a little bit
awkward but I I may do something like
this if the rook is having to defend
like that there in the the bishops eyes
are the bishops view yeah it was a that
was a nice timely move there I guess I
guess I should have been capturing the
knight on f3 95 was just strong combined
with those ideas capture and then Queen
takes my loose piece on g4 we'll have a
look at it as usual after the game let's
see how this plays out again I don't
feel that it is a full pawn advantage
here but maybe I could do this and if
the bishop captures then I get here and
if it captures this then maybe this is
annoying
my bishops are controlling some squares
some coordination right around here
mm-hmm okay almost like they are sensing
my thoughts here sensing my thoughts
anticipating my moves
c4 around the corner fish up there let's
get hooked to b7 in and now how to
defend the beep on they can't feel so
comfortable defending the beep on it
seems like it hits at a snail's pace but
I'm going to look for this stuff
hitting at b2 they're catching up on the
clock here one minute advantage yeah
let's let's keep going
I'm not quite sure what I would do if
Rick should be one is played but at
least I'm now at a point where you know
I'm able to put pressure on the beep on
how to defend oh okay well can I take
here hmm let's capture first see how
white recaptures the night is and
interesting the night capture is
interesting okay probably should get
over here now let's go to it with this
rook stay on the light square if I do
this I'm asking for some trouble skewers
keep my Brooks on light squares they may
try to resolve this tension by applying
pressure Bishop e3 now they take so they
gave up their center point
all right let's recapture in a block
with the bishop no wow
okay well what to do here this probably
get my bishop somewhere huh let's go
here you might want to reroute my bishop
here I'm just I don't want to obstruct
my f-pawn nor do I want to run into this
type of move with tempo though for the
moment it's still pinned um let's get
the H pawn rollin Bishop g7 bishops on
adjacent diagonal is what I want to keep
that night under control he's ready to
not be under control anymore so where to
go with my king
hmm I have to get out of the line of
fire
I think this is a strong move Wow sneaky
sneaky sneaky I may have to do without
the to play Bishop back and rook back
think he's too much I'm an inconvenience
too much if I'm going for that kind of
stuff so there goes the bishop pair I
guess there's those ideas as well maybe
I got expand now
try to restrict this beep on advance
let's stay active here that night
spinned I have this as a threat I'll
never allow that and just look to double
up next okay
hmmm let's just box out some squares
here this is oh I have to be very
careful this is getting serious now
okay they broke that up just in the nick
of time
this night is still boxed out not
anymore though hmm that's a good move
now defend that pond
the night's going to hit it play rook to
d7 not fun to do this there's a knight
Chuck I gotta play King to f8 I have a
rock on the seventh you know you can you
test my rook here need to get rid of
that night
poof
tie game
strong move I guess have to take giving
up a big square to the night but yeah b4
is strong I want to get rid that night
and maybe try to draw this ending you
know I take my rook first Wow Oh King
here strong playing strong game in
strong game Oh King takes fun I have
this I'm not going to do that pretty
sure they're not going to do that and
this is definitely lost be throwing in
the towel soon I don't know why they
didn't just grab that pawn I guess this
is still winning
you've worked it out yeah now's a good
time to resign who tough one they played
some strong moves right there in that
end game good game
Bishop e7 is what I'm thinking there was
an issue with Bishop to e7 let's have a
look at it maybe I did need to capture
the knight on f3 huh
Queen b6 right here issue with Bishop e7
or not a big moment I could always take
here and then do this I don't have
issues here I give my opponent the
bishop here but this is a this should be
fine but yeah it was quite timely there
after I played Bishop e7 let's let's
dive right in with the evaluation and
see see what it has to say let's put the
let's put it on likes Knight to e5 is
this the suggestion oh I could also look
to question the bishop before Bishop to
e7 that was another move hmm a six first
I'd probably take with the Queen and you
know I'm still playing with the bishop
pair like in the game but I'm not down
upon hmm a six Bishop e7 there's an
issue with it as natural as it looks
there is a way to take advantage I
didn't really see I didn't appreciate
this double attacking idea
appreciates the wrong word I just I
didn't I didn't see the combined threats
well enough at least it's 95 takes here
it's a problem yeah it's a problem I
went with 86 yeah but I'm down upon now
hmm okay so the other thing that I
pointed out was I could also capture
here doesn't like that as best but I
could do this kind of stuff if they're
jumping in pretty level but yeah I guess
I should have challenged this this
bishop sooner instead of this move I'm
just one move away but one move away was
not good enough for this in this
position one move out 95 is strong one
more to say I was never better
there should be five castles Bishop e7
yeah I can't go with Bishop e7 hmm okay
you know a six is better and then
playing this position they want to take
you now I wouldn't give up the
light-square bishop in this case
if there isn't some quick way to take
advantage of me being down timewise here
or let's say the weaknesses that I have
over here
I should this should be an advantage for
me I mean this is a long-term thing
Bishop pair okay well I didn't see this
combined idea of the bishop now punching
it g7 and also this stuff just to show
if I do that there's this and then that
if I take here there's first this
capture and then if I recapture there
goes my bishop Cambridge Springs like
hmm okay noted I can't just go with a
very normal ish move here 95 is strong
strong repot chop-chop
I gotta go with a 6 they take first
guess they have their pick Bishop takes
Knight or Bishop takes pawn Bishop takes
pawn right there there we go yeah I
thought about this hmm
something like that I thought about
maybe I I don't know I think he could be
worked around ok what did I do
also again just to illustrate if I do
this there's Bishop g3 as otherwise
these are situations I'll be picking up
the exchange if there isn't a move like
this threatening the capture if he
pushes there goes through so I can't get
that pawned back down upon and one more
thing up
played a good game good one Bishop f4 it
doesn't like Bishop f4 the past spot
Rick b7 may look a little bit awkward to
do this but I mean I can't really get at
that night able to fight back just a
little bit here I have some pressure
against the deep on hmm yeah I thought
Bishop block would but would have been
better it's a pretty level here even
though up upon lights up upon yeah I
guess as soon as I give up the dark
square Bishop I'm in some trouble huh no
I collapsed too easily I thought this
was starting to be a bit much you know
the threat here is I don't know just to
activate the night I thought at least
okay well I have a timely f6 move but if
I'm taking here just to show this is one
of the ideas or the main idea really why
white did that so I want to make sure he
wasn't getting activated so easily but I
guess I don't I guess I could be meeting
this move with that pitching upon and I
could get the knight next I didn't look
at any of that I just thought I'm being
too convenient by this bishop and I
should like to get rid of them but yeah
I just exchanged the bishop even likes
me here a little bit Wow being down upon
huh rook there king up I double and I
guess
I should be capturing here mmm
I really didn't want to do that this was
a good maneuver this was a really good
maneuver this night he was I mean what
move was it that he went to d2 he was on
d2 for forever but as soon as he played
here and there was these uh attacks
against d5 and he became very annoying
fast I went with f6 and yeah the capture
is strong night f1 good maneuver there
on d5 and now I'm I'm defending so I
should have excuse me I should have
captured here and then on Knight takes
Bishop takes and then try to play this
okay I should go for this kind of a
exchange of pieces and try to hold this
end game mmm I do have active rooks so
that counts for something yeah I
collapsed too easily this was a guy I
didn't uh I didn't consider this capture
right here
when I played f6 ours my hopes were
getting up some you know looking at this
move but that's all squashed any idea of
expanding like that if they make the
passing move like this they could be in
some trouble which push push I start to
control some dark squares I start to
have some nice coordination between my
bishop and structure but they were quick
to break it up good move good move and
now I'm on the defensive which is no fun
and yeah not a losing advantage but yeah
b4 is a good move
and that pawn went really fast Bishop
takes rook takes here's best I just
thought I surprised to see rook takes
rook first but very precise taking the
rook first
and then that way after this captures
their there on this guy it's probably
still winning either way if they do it
like that but yeah they were right on
top of that and then this is gone King
takes pawn look at that it's still I'm
not even winning here that's cool I
would have figured I'd be winning
I guess he's fast enough yeah that's
cool
King over push check here check there
improve the king I mean I could just
keep going back and forth but could I
just do this and still be winning or not
winning but would it be a draw just want
to test this out can I not just approach
with my king no I guess he's going to
get there fast enough just to be on the
safe side I could just I could only hope
for a draw in this in this type of an
endgame if I'm giving up my rook for the
pawn I could only hope for a draw and
getting getting here fast enough because
this is this and this can happen fast so
I could always just go back and forth
but I mean just pointing out that little
tactic interesting to see that it would
be a draw even being down a rook and
yeah well this is just gone timing is
not there at all
rook right behind the pond yeah I'm
trying to get this in but I think even
if I did get it in it's still it still
wouldn't be savable if I don't know the
pawn pushes it's still gone I get behind
but - King here and he'll be hunted down
I'm already down one pawn and soon to be
another good game my opponent they took
advantage
my Bishop e7 move very nicely was down
upon and it was an uphill battle from
there had some chances in the end to
still keep it equal get to see how the
computer of course evaluates or values
the bishop pair there's still some fight
in the position even though I was down
upon but uh in that ending once it got
to this point I should be capturing
right here it's important I do this
right now and try to play a rook and
pawn endgame this is yeah this is what I
should have been looking into just as I
referenced one more thing to note here
just as I referenced maybe right around
this point I think I was saying maybe I
could try to steer it into an opposite
color Bishop ending because there's a
stronger chance that it'll turn into a
drop and that's really the best I could
hope for being down upon in this
position on a similar note I should also
be considering entering a rook specific
endgame and I had my option I had a
chance to do that right about here with
this capture they not to take with the
knight of course they could take with
the pawn but then but then I could look
to maybe control some dark squares with
this the f6 and ecig structure I really
didn't I never even considered that this
from here on out f6 takes I'm in trouble
a very good reposition of the night and
he hit the position really hard
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye
you